but we've got to begin with the breaking
news about the primary election results
in five different states including a
highly charged senate primary in
pennsylvania the republican race there
is still too close to call at this hour
tv celebrity doctor that's dr mamanaz
leads david mccormick by less than 1 000
votes meanwhile madison cawthorne the
youngest u.s congressman and one of the
most controversial lost his primary race
in north carolina robert cost is in
yardley pennsylvania been a long night
for you bob former president trump back
hawthorne and dr oz so what do these
results say about his endorsement power
and talk about every vote counts in
pennsylvania this is a this is a nail
biter in that city this morning good
morning to you
good morning to you gail what we learned
last night was that former president
trump's endorsement it can be rocket
fuel for a candidate in a republican
primary but it's by no means a guarantee
of victory in north carolina congressman
madison cawthorne has conceded defeat
following issues surrounding his
personal conduct and in pennsylvania dr
memidaz had the endorsement of the
former president but he's locked in a
race that's a toss-up right now with
businessman david mccormick a former
hedge fund manager who has been allied
with the former president but did not
get his endorsement they're going to
have a likely recount here in
pennsylvania if the race between
mccormick and oz is within half a
percent
so if we have a recount it could be
another few days before we have an
answer in that particular race
on the democratic side that's exactly
right
yeah and people want to know the results
of this one cbs news is projecting let's
talk about lieutenant governor john
fetterman now he won the democratic
senate senate nomination but as you know
he's in the hospital he's recovering
from a stroke he just had successful
surgery to install a pacemaker so he's
making it clear i'm going to be okay and
i'm ready to go how will his health do
you think affect his campaign moving
forward
it did not affect the final result a
commanding victory in the democratic
primary for the six foot eight
lieutenant governor he is now going to
be the democratic nominee in the fall
here in pennsylvania such a critical
state both in 2022 and in 2024 for both
parties fetterman is going to be working
closely with attorney general josh
shapiro who won the gubernatorial
nomination last night here in
pennsylvania
yeah you know we had we had a story on
him yesterday bob and his wife said i
made him go to the doctor it turns out
she did the right thing it seems
donald trump also endorsed doug
mastriano he won the gop nomination from
pennsylvania governor so how do you
think his win could shape the midterm
race there
he's running against josh shapiro dale
we're good
we're going to be keeping a close eye on
state senator doug mastriano this is
someone who is in washington organizing
participants in
trump's january 6 2021 rally he has been
an election denier he has also been
outspent so far but in a big way by
attorney general shapiro the democratic
nominee this is an important race for
democrats in a tough year can they win
in a state like pennsylvania against
someone like masteriano who appeared in
washington was part of the whole january
6 protest it's going to be quite a test
here in the keystone state
and isn't josh shapiro pretty popular in
that state
he has
built a record going after consumer
issues he's also
prosecuted and investigated uh members
of the catholic church the clergy for
different
aspects of personal misconduct so he has
a national profile to bring to this
gubernatorial race and you have him and
fetterman doing the both have a lot of
attention nationally from democrats
all eyes on pennsylvania once again bob
we thank you